moi il me semble tout de même qu'il ya
une impression de trahison qui ai vécu
une bonne partie de la population sur
cette planète aussi bien disons parce
qu'ils s'engagent du côté de boko haram
dans les pays sahéliens que par disons
les hindous nationaliste qui suivent la
folie de maudit ou bien pas pour le
palais tropisme américain ou encore
parce que c'est le gris site en
angleterre ou encore ceux qui votent
marine le pen en france c'est à dire de
cette manière les lumières quand même
emporté avec elle la promesse d'une
prospérité partagée
est ce donc cela beaucoup font
l'expérience assez d'une explosion des
inégalités d'une pauvreté croissante
pour une partie d'entre nous et donc
quand même d'une trahison de ses
promesses quand même moi je parlerai
bien aussi de ressentiment oui la
vis-à-vis de cette promesse trahie qui
est à mon avis cette trahison elle même
et ré sa demande lui de mon point de vue
à 10 ans c'est ce mouvement post libéral
qui a complètement largué les amarres
avec le disons le projet des lumières
puisqu'ils larzac réaliser le pouvoir
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ils
bafouent l'état de droit ils essaient
d'absolu teese est la propriété privée
ce qui est une bêtise
donc c'est ce grand programme de
privatisation du monde de
marchandisation de la nature qui à la
fois produit les deux nuls
le désastre écologique auquel nous
assistons et dont nous sommes maintenant
déjà les victimes et le creusement des
inégalités qui détruit le lien social
[Musique]